hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and the heroes
just made a massive mistake a mistake
that could lead them to lose this entire
War like literally Heroes will die
because of what just happened in the
story and I don't think the heroes
realize that this one factor that they
didn't account for is about to ruin
their entire master plan they spent so
much time and resources trying to trap
all for one and shigaraki and in the end
it looks like it's all gonna be for
nothing so yeah things are about to get
really interesting and really deadly so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our mha content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now to
help us out with that YouTube algorithm
and of course subscribing is a
completely free but extremely important
way of directly supporting the channel
you can also hit us up on Twitter and
Instagram at animeoutpro and Twitter in
particular has been quite the chaotic
mess lately least so you know if you're
on there hit us up finally this video
will of course contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so in the previous
chapter Shoji tried to reason with the
other heteromorphs who were preparing to
attack the hospital as literally
thousands of them were about to follow
spinner and assault the hospital along
with him Shoji told them that what
they're doing isn't helping anyone
attacking vulnerable civilians inside
the hospital some of whom are
heteromorphs themselves will not only
fail to advance their cause it will
actually make things worse if Society
sees that thousands of heteromorphs are
capable of attacking a hospital full of
civilians than the stigma against them
will only increase and the people who
are hurt today at the hands of these
heteromorphs will one day seek revenge
against them and their children and this
horrible cycle of violence will continue
endlessly spinner and that plf Commander
tried their best to keep Shoji's words
from reaching the angry masses but bit
by bit Shoji's arguments and his
willingness to sacrifice himself for his
ideals began to break through the anger
of the crowd when people saw how fellow
heteromorphs like Shoji and Koda were
fighting bravely on the side of the
heroes and when they saw fellow
heteromorph civilians putting their
bodies on the line in order to protect
the hospital they started second
guessing themselves after all we have to
remember that most of these mutant Quirk
users who are in the crowd don't want to
hurt innocent people or commit crimes
all they really want at the end of the
day is to be treated fairly and the
villains had convinced them that
violence was the only way to get their
point across but Shoji Coda and the
other heteromorphs who are fighting on
the side of the heroes showed the crowd
that there is another way and slowly but
surely the angry masses became less
angry and they lost their desire for
violence and destruction at the end of
the previous chapter we saw spinner
making his way through the hospital in
the belief that he was a leader now and
that thousands of heteromorphs were
following behind him ready to fight for
him spinner thought that he had finally
become someone who matters someone like
his hero stain but in reality by the
time that spinner reached kurogiri he
was on his own no one was following him
anymore except for present Mike who came
there to stop him from breaking kurogiri
out the latest chapter gives us a bit
more insight into how exactly spinner
came to be alone in the end and I'm
actually glad that we got more info on
this because in the previous chapter it
did feel a little sudden it was like one
moment everyone is behind spinner and
the next they all have a change of heart
we now see that after spinner launched
himself towards the hospital present
Mike immediately went after him as he
departed he left it up to Shoji and Koda
to hold the other villains and Riders
back so that spinner wouldn't get back
up at one point Shoji nearly gets
smashed in the back of the head by a
heteromorph holding a stick but before
he can hurt Shoji his hand is stopped by
another heteromorph this other mutant
Quirk user appears to have some physical
features of a pig and this guy was
actually part of the angry mob but
Shoji's words and actions have gotten
through to him and he has realized that
what they're doing is wrong as he looks
at the innocent and scared people who
have been endangered by Spinner's attack
on the hospital this heteromorph says
that he doesn't think that this is a
good use for his rage the plf commander
who is still being pinned down by all
those birds that Koda summoned screams
out that the heteromorphs can't let the
heroes intimidate them they have to keep
moving forward and fighting for their
leader spinner he is urging the mutant
Quirk users to embrace their rage and to
take revenge on the society that has
shunned them the man with the pig-like
features says that he knows all of that
pain and rage well he has been attacked
multiple times just because he was born
with that unique appearance and he was
all swept up in the moment and ready to
follow the lead of the villains but now
he realizes that there has to be a
better way it's clear that the whole
world isn't the enemy of the
heteromorphs after all there are plenty
of heteromorphs who are heroes and
doctors and policemen and other
important members of society there are
bad people out there for sure people who
discriminate against heteromorphs even
if the heteromorphs didn't do anything
wrong but at the same time there clearly
are some people who are good and who
don't deserve to be hurt if they
continue with this Mission the villains
and the writers will end up hurting good
innocent people and if they they do
there's no going back from that the plf
commander is furious that Shoji's logic
managed to get through to the Riders
because the villains had done such a
good job of indoctrinating them and
manipulating them he tries to Rally the
crowd and to push them into continuing
the attack but it's clear that a whole
bunch of people in the crowd are having
serious doubts about their actions they
are all angry about the injustices they
suffered they do want real change and
they want it immediately but at the same
time they don't want to become the kind
of people who hurt the innocent they
don't want to become villains with tears
in his eyes Shoji tells them that the
feeling that brought them here is not
wrong they are simply reacting to the
very real pain that has been a fact of
life for all of them for a long time in
that moment the other Heroes the ones
who are not heteromorphs begin reaching
out to the mutant Quirk users who are
gathered there these other Heroes
apologize that they weren't sensitive to
their struggles and they pledged to do
better in the future Shoji tells his
fellow heteromorphs that they should
work together to change the minds of
people who have misconceptions about
them and once everyone understands that
heteromorphs are normal people just like
everyone else it will be considered
shameful and socially unacceptable to
discriminate against them these hopeful
words begin to reverberate through the
crowd and eventually the entire angry
mob is pacified and that is why spinner
ended up alone because the crowd
abandoned the mission that the villains
were pushing them into and the remaining
villains like the plf commander were
subdued by the heroes with the crowd
calm the heroes switched their focus to
the hospital because while spinner is
now alone he is still dangerous and if
he can somehow awaken kurogiri the
heroes will be in massive trouble we
have to remember that kurogiri has the
power to teleport shigaraki Sasha all
for one out of range of izawa's quirk
Erasure and if that happens even for a
moment shigaraki Sasha all for one will
have access to all of his many many
overpowered quirks and if that happens
the game will change completely back in
the room where kurogiri is being kept
present Mike manages to knock spinner
down with a Sonic attack this attack
also breaks the recorder that spinner
was carrying the recorder which
contained the voices of all for one and
shigaraki in which he had planned to use
to awaken kurogiri as a nomu kurogiri is
programmed to obey the orders of his
master so kind of like what we saw with
gigantomakia just hearing a recording of
his master's voice should be enough to
get him moving but that plan has clearly
failed the recorder is destroyed and
Spinner is now on the ground and he is
back to his normal form his
gigantification has fallen off those big
scales that he had on his body have
fallen off and he is is an absolute mess
his mind still isn't functioning
properly and he can't even put simple
sentences together and even in this
warped State Spinners suddenly realizes
that his dream of becoming important and
a hero for his friends has collapsed
right in front of him he failed to
complete his mission he has no way of
Awakening kurogiri without that
recording and his desire to make shiraki
proud has gone unfulfilled present Mike
thinks that he may have succeeded here
and he wonders what his friend shirakuma
would say if he knew that izava lost an
eye and a leg in the recent battles
against the villains president Mike
clearly wishes that there was some way
of bringing his friend shirakumu back
but if there isn't then he wishes that
kurugiri would just disappear or just
never wake up the pain that both he and
Isa will feel at the loss of their
friend shirakumo is massive and of
course the fact that his body is now
being manipulated by the villains makes
things even worse but as it turns out
spinner is not done yet he brought with
him one of the hands that shigaraki once
carried as part of his costume and
actually it seems to be the father hand
that shigaraki carried over his face the
hand fell out when spinner collapsed to
the ground and the side of the hand gave
him a new sense of purpose and
determination spinner manages to get
back to his feet he grabs the hand and
he places it over kurogiri's face then
he tells kurogiri let's save shigaraki
and the others as present Mike calls out
to his friend shirakumo kurogiri
suddenly awakens and the black mist that
his Quirk normally produces begins to
grow and spread but the awakened
kurogiri looks a bit different he seems
to have one normal eye like before but
his left eye looks like a human eye
shirakumo's eye the chapter ends as
kurogiri says I am the one who protects
but as he says this he uses the first
person pronoun ore which is the pronoun
that was normally used by shirakumo not
kurogiri and as the narration on the
final page tells us that kurogiri is
about to join the battle and that the
war has reached a new stage we are left
to wonder how much of this awakened
kurogiri is the kurogiri we know and how
much of it is actually shirakumo does
the fact that his one eye looks human
and the fact that he used ore mean that
shirakumo is beginning to awaken within
kurogiri does this mean that kurogiri is
about to have a split personality and a
part of him will want to fight for the
villains while a part of him will want
to support the heroes does his vow to
protect shigarakitomura mean that he may
have to turn against all for one when he
realizes that all for one is a actually
the one trying to take over shigaraki's
body by force are we about to witness
full power shigaraki with all of his
quirks thanks to kurogiri's warp gate
this is a lot to think about and we are
definitely entering a new and very
dangerous stage of the war I've said
this before but I think kurogiri will
primarily be a villain at first and his
Quirk will allow shigaraki Sasha over
one to reach his full power that's
because this is a Shonen and let's be
real no one wants to see the final
villain defeated before he has a chance
to show us his full power shigaraki
regaining the use of his quirks will
then push Deku to get even stronger he
will experience Quirk Singularity and
his seven different quirks will all
merge into one super Quirk that has been
my theory for a while and I'm sticking
to it nevertheless I do think that
eventually kurogiri will revert back to
shirakumo and he will help the heroes
that that's because I believe that
shirakumo is not a corpse he is still
alive within kurogiri the base for the
nomu known as kurogiri was not the
corpse of shirakumo rather it was the
injured but still living body of
shirakumo which is why kurogiri was such
an intelligent and advanced nomu even
though he was made like two decades ago
with all of that said though I do think
that the heroes are about to pay a very
heavy price for allowing kurogiri to be
released I mean I know that the heroes
are understaffed and that they couldn't
split up their forces too much but
leaving only present Mike and a few
other heroes in charge of protecting
something as important as kurogiri was a
big mistake the fact that kurogiri was
not in a top secret location but in a
public hospital that the villains could
easily find was just a terrible move and
we are likely going to see some serious
consequences as a result of this
screw-up by the heroes once shigaraki
all for one gains the ability to use his
quirks again he will likely take charge
of the battlefield and launch some
devastating attacks and I think that
some Heroes and maybe even hero students
will die as a result of those attacks
before Deku finds a way to take one for
all to the next level the tragic deaths
that he witnesses will infuriate Deku
and push him to take that final step
towards Quirk Singularity so yeah if
we're being real I know the situation
that the heroes are in is very difficult
but the failure to keep kurogiri in
custody is going to have serious
repercussions and straight up the heroes
really screwed up on this one again I
know it's a difficult War I know they're
outnumbered but this is a major mistake
and a costly one as we are about to find
out let me know what you guys think do
you agree with my speculations about
what is going to happen next and are we
about to see some deadly consequences as
a result of the hero's failure to keep
kurogiri under wraps is kurogi going to
remain a villain will he revert back to
being shirakumo or are we going to see
something in between finally will
kurogiri break the effect of Erasure and
allow shigaraki Sasha all for one to
reach his full potential let me know
down below I always love hearing from
you if you guys enjoyed this mha video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment it helps
me out a lot and if you are one of the
over 50 percent of people who watch our
videos but are not subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications subscribing is
completely free and it is a very real
way to directly support the channel
right now you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at animeoproar Big
thank you to all of our anime outpro
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to trucker
Tim a disciple of Lord twigo himself and
I can't forget all of our the one team
your patrons including Alpha Sigma Pate
hefa The Toasted Qi Cory McGowan own
Taylor and Anime s kodam finally thank
you to all of our other patrons
including Pro Hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh Angel Cruz Alicia
Octor Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alivenia Sandy and the school bus if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys